assalamu alaikum your highness your
excellencies ladies and gentlemen good
evening we are truly proud to be the
country partner of the 5th Global
Education and Skills forum indeed our
participation tonight with the Minister
of Education Valerius Adeli represents
another sign of Italy's long-standing
commitment to culture and education we
are committed to promote them also
through our convince support to UNESCO
of which we are the second global
contributor and to most valuable
initiatives such as the Global Education
and Skills forum and the global teacher
prize I would like to congratulate the
organizers for a very successful
conference that is shining a spotlight
on the importance of global citizenship
and the importance of teachers i have
seen italian top 50 finalists amanda
persico being interviewed on TV and in
the newspapers a great teacher finally
being given the attention that he
deserves we in Italy were so inspired by
the brilliant idea of the global teacher
price that we launched our own national
t-shirt price you wouldn't believe how
much it has captured the public
imagination we have received thousands
of nomination from Milan in the north of
Italy to Naples in the south but most
importantly it has sparked thousands of
conversations across our country about
the role of teachers for the society I
would also like to extend a huge thank
you to his highness sheikh mohammed bin
rashid al maktoum thank you for your
support for the teaching profession your
patronage of this prize and your
continued efforts to promote peace and
tolerance I would also like to
congratulate
the Varkey foundation for your
commitment to education throughout the
world I wish the top 10 finalists the
best success but never forget that you
are doing the most important job in the
world you might not be told very often
good luck buona fortuna